[Music]
[Music]
I'm the one
not just a terrible movies out outside
of the fact there's terrible movies out
Avatar's not a date movie yeah the first
date movie anyways we're struggling here
with Adam Adams trying to go on a date
to see what movie to go to uh kids made
some comedy not comedy cartoon
recommendations but I think you want to
stick to a movie anyways yeah we have a
special guest today we have a Reza Aslan
in the house today if you don't know him
you may have heard his number one New
York Times best-selling book uh Zealot
The Life and Times of Jesus of Nazareth
he's written a few other books I think
he's written four books on the topic of
religion uh uh uh there's a no God but
God I can go on and on about the things
that he's done multiple New York Times
bestseller recent book that just came
out which we'll talk about later on
today as well an American martyr in
Persia found that he's a presbyterian
which is fantastic well he he he he is
not you he is you're definitely not a
presbyterian which we'll get into but uh
he's a Raiders fan his uh aunt is I
believe
which in the Iranian Community if you
don't know that's a very very big deal
yes it's like saying your aunt is uh I
share yeah it's like no no like
literally that's what that is do you
believe yeah and we had a show on CNN
he's done a lot of stuff he loves
debates maybe he does I don't know if he
does love debates he seems to like
debates he's been on the bill Marshall
multiple times he's been on all over I
mean if you turn on if you go on CNN you
you uh if you go on Google you search
his name on YouTube uh you'll see a ton
of different interviews Reza thank you
so much for coming out and meeting
yesterday some good stuff some bad stuff
some good stuff some bad stuff yes no
it's a pleasure to be here but but that
that's that's the part about to me at
least for me
my interest is
sitting with people that have some good
stuff some good bad stuff some
controversial stuff that's what makes
for interesting if you're playing it too
safe yeah uh that's boring it's just
that I don't think that's the route to
go well look my primary fields are
religion and politics that's not exactly
very peaceful polite polite conversation
great kitchen table topics that never
causes you guys want to talk about doing
Thanksgiving here listen you want to go
religion or politics here you should go
either way I'm simultaneously the most
interesting uh dinner guest and the
worst yeah yeah I've been a guest known
for very short loud dinners yes that's
right well I mean you know one one thing
I I uh respect about you is how much you
admired the Trump family like your level
of yeah you know when I when I see true
the your your tweets man it was just
like constant admiration love it was
like nonstop a little too much honesty
if you I'm all about making America
great again
okay so that that should kind of give
you an idea if you don't know who he is
we're being hardcore sarcastic for the
people that take things literal anyways
Reza if you don't mind take a quick
moment give the audience who doesn't
know your background uh I was born in
Iran yep in 1972 which makes me 50 which
is insane
uh thank you I appreciate that uh
uh my family was you know like an upper
middle class family landowning uh family
big large uh tribal family my father uh
was a kind of a troublemaker
um communist uh evenings today exactly
yeah yep yep uh but like college today
the way that all college kids are sort
of communist do you know so you know my
family too yeah so my mother said so two
day today if you want to share with the
audience what today is so today was the
primary Communist party in Iran in the
1970s and it actually had a massive role
in the success of the 1979 Revolution
that got rid of the Shaw and that
eventually about a little more a little
less than a year later uh replaced the
Shah with Khomeini whose First Act was
to get rid of all the Communists
so it's just kind of crazy they thought
they were going to make it better for
two days but it got worse for them they
thought they could control the religious
Fanatics and if they're if there's not a
lesson there
then you're not paying attention right
it's I think the Communist party they
were the intellectuals of the movement
they gave the movement uh teeth and they
helped uh I think you know less
politically minded people understand
exactly what was at stake in this
revolution but in the end it's the
religious uh leaders who have the
ability to bring people out onto the
streets right ideas don't go anywhere if
there aren't thousands of people willing
to risk their bodies in order to
implement those ideas and so it was this
weird marriage
of convenience to begin with right these
like secularist mainly atheists uh
intellectuals and communists
and the religious Pious masses they
married together to get rid of the Shah
but then as soon as the Shah was gone
the cracks in that relationship very
quickly formed and and I remember very
clearly my father uh one morning very at
least for my seven-year-old perspective
very suddenly saying it's time to go we
got we got to go right one year this was
79 so oh you left in 79. so it left
after the Shah uh left left after
Khomeini arrived where did you live
where in Iran did you live in Tehran
what part of Tehran oh we were in the
north okay yeah yeah nice area yeah
we're the nicer area we had we had
things gone what city would you say if
you've gone the area like what area do
you remember the area or no I don't
remember the exactly there was an area
like if you lived in the north you're
like
to say what would be the you know
uh it's like saying you lived in Beverly
Hills type of area maybe not Beverly
Hills but it's like to say you live in a
good area yeah well I will say that like
those people the the very rich people
they got the message way before anybody
else
they all got out with their Swiss bank
accounts uh intact and have you been
back to Iran since you left in 79 just
once I went back in 2005 before I I was
anyone and when I could just kind of you
know sneak under the the radar yeah
um it was this was right after Ahmad uh
became president good time it was like
yeah it was a crazy time and I went back
for about eight nine weeks
um on a research trip but also to see my
family to see my you know the home and
just to kind of see what the place was
like
um that's probably the last time I'll
get to see Ron what would happen if you
went back now and and what do you think
would happen if someone like Pat would
go back now because that's a lifelong
dream of his I just don't know the
reality of it I think
I think that if I went back now uh I
would probably be never heard from again
I'd probably disappear at the airport I
think if Pat went back now he would be
welcomed with open arms and then someone
would knock on his door a few days later
and say you sent a text uh and that text
makes you a spy come with us
does there need to be any justification
for them you know taking you away or is
it just that the theocrats are just
gonna come get you and that's just how
it works see here's here's the The Awful
Truth about Iran is that there are a lot
of ways that we could label it that it's
a Theocratic regime or that it's a
fascist regime or that it's like a
military regime
but the truth of the matter is that like
most autocratic States
it's impossible to really know who's in
charge of what right the the person in
charge of your life is the guy on the
other side of the desk
you know if he's a bureaucrat yeah if
he's had a nice lunch
and uh and you know had a nice
conversation with his wife then maybe
you're okay if he had a fight with his
wife then you're screwed and and it's
not like you can point to the law to say
but that's not how it works right
um in countries like Iran the law is
whatever the person in front of you says
the law is and that makes these kinds of
situations very difficult so when an
American citizen of Iranian Heritage
which happens quite often uh gets
arrested and accused of these sort of
very vaguely worded crimes
um it's very hard for the the American
government to kind of do anything
legally to support them because the law
is such an absolute mess over there is
there is there a law in Iran an
established constitutional law that
provides for uh a fair judicial process
for anyone committed who who is uh
allegedly committed a crime yeah
absolutely does anyone pay any attention
to that no I mean you can appeal to it
but people just sort of laugh at you
that's the problem with not just Iran
but all of these sort of autocratic
States police go back to the to the
upbringing so I'm following I'm tracking
all of it that today it's kind of a
rebel like the younger ones like you
know two days in a movie theater you
would stand up to kind of give
recognition to the Shah and two days
wouldn't stand up like they would do
they were rep they were like stuff like
that yeah and then go ahead continue
we're listening so seven years old you
guys that you're the your dad says we
got to get out of here 79 right before
Khomeini right after Shaw you guys leave
you come to the states yeah and and I
think for my dad too people don't people
forget that when how many how many Jesus
when Khomeini returned just so you know
to Americans it's the same thing but to
us yes no yes
when he corrected himself Americans are
like what is he doing please
but there's a big difference yes
would you for the for us uh Gringo
Americans pronounce the different names
was the founder of the Islamic Republic
and and the guy who invented the very
idea of the Supreme leader Khamenei is
the current Supreme so say the two names
do totally separate words it is exactly
doesn't sound anything alike anyway the
point is is that you know when he came
back I think people people don't
remember this when he when he uh
returned from Exile in in Iran there's
millions of people came out you know to
sort of Welcome him as the savior of the
of the new Iran he very publicly
announced that he wanted nothing to do
with politics that he had no interest in
government that you know he was happy
that the Shah was gone but he just
wanted to be left alone he wanted to go
back to his home and to his family into
his mosque into his studies and my dad
who never trusted anything anyone
wearing a turban had to say on any
subject just thought
[ __ ] like that's I don't believe
that for a minute and so just in case
let's grab some things and go and if it
if it does turn out okay we'll come back
you know let's just leave for a little
bit so that's what it was it was very it
was really an emergency thing you know
wake up in the morning grab some things
put it in a suitcase we're gonna just
leave for a little while
and that was obviously what you guys go
to that's great here or did you go like
to Spain and then you came here was it
like a inner uh we there was a brief
stop in London for a lot of Iranians
checking out London was like stop number
one uh but that's funny for us our
destination in the United States was
Oklahoma
was Enid Oklahoma and I to this day I
can't tell you exactly why my my my
theory is that when my dad was in
college he did like a semester abroad at
a at a university in Oklahoma I think in
Edmonton I believe I don't remember
Eastern Oklahoma I'm sorry Oklahomans
that I am unaware of your geology just
throw them under the bus
um and I think he just thought well
that's America like that's Oklahoma is
America and Bread Basket so if we go to
America then we're going to land in
Oklahoma which by the way he's right in
a lot of ways but it only took us about
a year to realize oh there's so much
more about America and so like so many
Iranians we headed west and ended up in
California but in Northern California
not in Southern California different
Iranian diaspora where uh in the Bay
Area okay yeah I mean there's a big
Community there well the bear it's like
a different community so the first
Iranians who led the wealthy ones who
like took their money with them all
settled in Los Angeles and so there's a
reason we call La tarantulas you know
um and but then the sort of
intellectuals the second wave the
post-revolution people who got out they
all settled in the Bay Area so it's a
vastly different community in California
the Northern California Iranians in the
Southern California area so but for
today to escape to leave an escape
that that doesn't make sense though
because I'm assuming your dad was not a
fan of the shaw right no he was not a
family so so how
that is a very strange kudos to your dad
by the way for for making that decision
but for knowledge yeah because that
doesn't make sense though that doesn't
make because the level of hate today's
had for the Shah was so massive yeah
that they all wanted anything but the
Shah because obviously you know the
whole look how rich she is look at the
2500 Year celebration he put together
anything is better than the show this is
the thought well I'm surprised that he
left
and I think for my dad the the two-day
politics was married to a real
anti-religious hardcore atheist
materialism view yeah like I always joke
that my dad was the kind of atheist who
always had a pocket full of prophet
Muhammad jokes that he would pull out at
inappropriate times you know what I mean
like he was a very kind of viral
virulently anti-religious
person how old were you the first time
you read Communist Manifesto
really I'm actually curious I mean
honestly it's probably not until I was
like 13 14. okay so you read it here you
didn't read it in Europe no yeah that
was like the Bible you know for two-day
party you know you have to read that to
get an understanding about bourgeoisie
and you know uh uh all the other guys
anyways okay so your your religious
ideology like how religious beliefs
you've you've kind of gone through a
little bit if you don't mind sharing
that with the audience well so you know
we grew up uh culturally Muslim the way
that so many people are culturally
religious around the world it was just
kind of part of who we were it was part
of our identity
um and you know we would go we would go
through the the rituals and the holidays
and all that stuff but when we came to
the US I think my father thought aha
well there now we don't even have to
pretend anymore like we don't have to
pay lip service to any of that you know
put the Quran away and and roll up the
prayer rugs and that's the end of that
my mother you know was raised a little
bit differently she was raised primarily
by my um
by her grandmother her parents were
famous actors you know in Iran which in
Iran is kind of another way of saying
prostitute
um and so she basically raised by by
just so you know he's right she was
basically raised by her very strict
grandmother and so you know my mother
would would pray every once in a while
and and
um we would do some of the holidays but
but the more we stayed in Iran the more
I grew up I'm sorry in the US the more I
grew up in the U.S
um the more and more we systematically
stripped our lives and our family of any
kind of religiosity but you have to
understand you know I was seven when my
country was handed over to religious
Fanatics and I remember it I was there
on the streets I watched it happen and
it I think instilled in me at a very
young age
with religion and the power that
religion has to transform a society for
good and for bad and and the way that
religion can be used as a way to uh to
make change but to also identify
yourself to create groups and in groups
out groups I got really fascinated by
Legends and mythologies
um I was just a weird boy like I was a
weird boy I was interested in religion
but in a family in which there was no
place to really Express that in any
meaningful way was your dad and now it
may make sense to me I'm assuming okay
so that makes sense of course
is like the original Bernie Sanders that
the shaw kicked out
you know he I would say he's the Bernie
Sanders yeah was Bernie Sanders and then
eventually what they did with him is
with the help of uh the stories or the
help of CIA the same way they got rid of
the show with the help of SIA and you
know Kissinger and Carter the same
Playbook they used with with most other
well a little more aggressive they
actually uh so put him in a village and
just the the the mossedek Revolution was
in 1953 uh where once again the Iranians
rose up kicked the Shah out of the
country this is the third time we we've
done this but not the not the young shot
the the father you're talking about no
no this was this is Muhammad Raza
pallavi yeah 53 that's right that's
right 50th Muhammad yeah the same shot
that left in 79. uh we threw him out and
replaced him with this nationalist
government at the head was the Prime
Minister Muhammad mosadec uh had very
radical sort of democratic nationalistic
ideas one of which was to nationalize
Iran's oil like why are we why are we
giving away our oil to the British uh
you know in exchange for rent like
literally that's what it was in exchange
for like they rent
the the the land and then extract the
oil and keep it
um and so we nationalized the oil uh the
British were obviously devastated by
that move but this was post-world War II
and the British were just this powerless
Island now you know that the empire was
gone
so they asked their good friends The
Americans
for help and this was when the CIA had
first been created uh it came from the
OSS from World War II but now the war's
gone so now we have this intelligence
apparatus what do we do with this until
we nobody had any idea what to do with
the CIA until a very clever clever uh
agent by the name of Kermit Roosevelt
um that I believe grandson of Teddy
Roosevelt I think or grand nephew of
Teddy Roosevelt came up with this great
idea and it was hey why don't we uh put
the shaw back on the throne I can do
that give me four guys in a suitcase
with a hundred thousand dollars in it
and that as absurd and as like Ocean's
11 as that sounds economic Hitman it's
just that was it there were like four
guys it was a boxer uh a Communications
nerd I mean why isn't this a movie
Kermit Roosevelt who's like this 97
pound coke bottle glasses wearing nerd
uh he looks like Joe Montana a couple of
other people and uh what a mustache no
does he not look like Joe Montana he's
like an elderly Joe Montana a little bit
right there yeah and uh and it took them
a couple of months and they went to Iran
in a couple of months they created a
fake counter protest removed mosadeg
from power and put the Shah back on the
throne and the British said thank you
very much we'll take the oil back now
and the Americans said no
no yeah we did all the work I think
we're just gonna stay and that was the
birth of the problematic relationship
between the U.S and Iran that then LED
in 79 to the anti-American Revolution do
you know the the 25-year contract
between that do you know the story about
the 25-year contract okay can you pull
up the 1954 oil Iran contract just type
that in it'll come up this is so
interesting with everything you're
saying where all the timing is now
making sense there you go the Consortium
agreement of 1954 zoom in a little bit
for us to read this they signed a
25-year contract
so the concerned agreement 1915 will
provide a western companies with 50
owners should be running an old
production after its ratification in
1954-79 despite the numerous
negotiations and offers the Shah of Iran
refused to extend agreement which
originally and clearly postulated that
the Consortium he had had the right to
prolong at least 15 years three times
five years anyways this thing is
expiring in 1979. so check this out 53
54 they signed a contract 25 years the
ownership I think is through with France
I want to say Obviously UK us and
there's one other country in that I
don't know if it's Germany or Dutch
Shell the Oriole Dutch Shell yeah so
they team it and then there's a meeting
which by the way this would be a very
interesting documentary to watch I
watched this I couldn't believe it there
was a meeting in in the South or Central
America by four uh leaders in 1978 or 77
deciding on how to make the shop about
fall
and because they knew the shot
specifically kept saying I'm increasing
prices I'm increasing prices once this
expires obviously they don't want him to
have that kind of power boom with the
help of that the next economic Hitman
comes in we got to replace the shop
Iran's been used by uh people of the
West for many many years
uh anyways okay so interesting
background story so from that you go you
become a Christian I think for four
years because you you I want to say you
were a Christian for four years at 14
years old yeah 15 years old so I mean
you know I was fascinated by religion
and spirituality no real place to
explore that at home A friend of mine
invited me to a Christian Youth Group in
high school
um and I was like all right and you know
it's like singing and games and and like
wholesome fun and entertainment and
camping trips it was awesome it was and
and also the gospel story which is a
pretty good story I'm not sure if you're
familiar with the story of Jesus we have
a two Christians and an atheist trying
to get back to being a presbyterian
again I mean look again whatever you
want to whatever wherever your spiritual
views are the story of the god of Heaven
and Earth coming down in the form of a
baby and then dying for everyone's sins
and then all you have to do is believe
that story and you'll never die is a
great story right and when you're 50 15
and you hear that you're like that's a
good story so I
fully 100 percent uh converted to this
very conservative brand of Evangelical
Christianity and then spread that story
to pretty much everyone I knew until
until I went to college and decided I'm
gonna study this stuff because it's so
great it's so fascinating who was the
who was a teacher that messed you up in
college
I'm actually curious to know who was it
a girlfriend or a teacher he was a
teacher I went to a Jesuit university
and it was the Catholics that screwed me
up the Jesuits who were like oh yeah you
believe that stuff
yeah intellectual uh priesthood in in
the in the Catholic Church how about
Santa Clara yeah at Santa Clara yeah
well modified Jesuits but yeah yeah like
like liberation theology Jesuits you
know that like that that hardcore uh uh
Jesuits
um they're the ones that turned you off
from Christianity it's after being such
a hardcore believer it's not that they
turned me off of Christianity it's that
they taught me the truth of the Gospel
message they they they told me about
Jesus the man instead of Jesus the
Christ right they told me about the
historical person who walked the Earth 2
000 years ago and said these things and
what the context of what he said meant
at the time and how we should read that
today as opposed to the sort of
spiritualization you know the
metaphysical aspect of the of the things
that he said the way that his incredibly
radical
revolutionary words and thoughts were
defanged by the first church and turned
into wishy-washy spiritualism or what we
now call Christianity
um they gave me an insight into
the the original idea of what he was
talking about how different are those
two ideas Jesus the man and Jesus who
became the Messiah how I mean Jesus the
Messiah has no concerns for the cares of
this world whatsoever
his only concern is you know the world
to come what does it matter what you eat
in this world and what does it matter
what you how you dress the only world
that matters is the world to come and
focus all your attention on that world
and not not the vagaries of this world
that's that's Jesus Christ
Jesus of Nazareth
was a radical revolutionary whose sole
Focus was on the suffering of the people
on this world right now and the power
structures that were creating that
suffering
the Jesus Jesus Christ is everyone's the
same we're all equal there's nothing
between rich and poor everyone's the
same
Jesus the man said
no the first shall be last and the last
shall be first the hungry will be will
be fed and those who are fed will go
hungry
right those who have will have it taken
away from them and those who don't have
will get it that's not we're all the
same that's the reversal of the social
order right that's the top and the
bottom switching places is that more of
a socialist component is that like a
Robin Hood who who would he be in a the
Jesus the man in a in a metaphoric
concept I mean I think he's got more in
common with Che Guevara than Robin Hood
I mean again Jesus at no point in any of
the gospels does Jesus talk about
everyone is equal everyone should have
the same that's not a that's not a Jesus
line right that the world that I see is
one in which everyone has the same
that's socialism the world that Jesus
talked about
quite a violent world it was a
revolutionary world and it was a world
in which the first became last and the
last became first
like that's not a that's not a popular
Viewpoint amongst you know the people in
the category of first it's it's
interesting though that they're the so
the Jesuits in Santa Clara made you look
at Jesus as the Messiah and the
individual so then you went through the
Journey there and then how did that
bring you back to Muslim well so the
kind of Evangelical Christianity that I
had ascribed to is very rigid
and at its core is this idea that the
Bible is literal and it is inerrant
and it takes 10 minutes
of research to discover that both of
those things are total [ __ ] like the
Bible is riddled with errors I mean
riddled with the most basic most obvious
contradictions and errors
um and that the idea that it should be
read literally you know makes no sense
at all and so once you start
understanding the chasm between the man
Jesus and how he became the Christ of
Christianity
it's really hard to continue to follow
the Christ of Christianity any longer
and so would you give some examples of
that by the way like the most palpable
errors that that you would just notice
immediately yeah sure so Matthew Mark
and Luke say that uh Jesus was crucified
on a Thursday uh and uh the Gospel of
John says it was like a Sunday so in
other words it was before the Passover
and the gospel John was after the
Passover
um you know Matthew uh has Jesus uh for
some strange reason going to Egypt uh
whereas Luke says has the same birth
story says nothing about Jesus um uh in
Matthew uh Jesus is born in what we
would now recognize as probably
um 10 A.D ish 8 or 10 A.D
um and in Luke Jesus is born and what we
now recognize at about 4 BC
um so uh you know it's there's all these
contradictions it's just very obvious
clear contradictions the reason the
reason I asked that because the obvious
question is whether it's the Bible
whether it's the Torah whether it's the
Quran should these books these relics be
taken literally or metaphorically not
only should they be taken metaphorically
they were never ever ever intended to be
read literally do you think
the authors the the author of Luke
who says that uh you know in the year uh
you know but I guess it's six six or six
A.D
um there is a census in Rome and the
census requires everyone in the entire
Roman Empire to stop what they are doing
and travel to their father's Homeland so
that they could be properly
counted
for a for the taxation purposes and so
Joseph who lived in Nazareth
had to travel to Bethlehem in order to
be counted because his parents family
was from Bethlehem
okay
there is no census of the entire Roman
Empire in 6 A.D there's a small census
in Syria but where Jesus lived did not
Encompass that census
census law under the Roman Empire is as
clear as it gets you get counted where
you live the purpose of sensate of a
census is taxation so we're here to
count your stuff how many people are you
and where's your stuff the idea that
every once in a while everyone in the
largest greatest richest Empire the
world had ever known would have to stop
what they were doing and travel for
months at a time to wherever their
forefathers were born in order and also
bring their stuff I guess in order to be
counted there is patently absurd and
unhistorical now here's the important
thing to understand about what I just
said
not only does It screw up the entire
Christmas story that you tell your kids
every day or every every Christmas
but Luke who wrote that knew that that
wasn't true he was living as a citizen
of the Roman Empire his readers for
Generations read that and knew that that
wasn't true that's not how sin the
census works I've gone through many
censuses and that's not how it works
they didn't care
because the idea the notion that what
was being read was meant to be read
literally would never have even occurred
to them
the idea that scripture is a thing to be
read historically and literally was born
of the 19th century
it's only been about a couple of hundred
years since the very notion of biblical
literalism has existed and it's existed
as a result of the Scientific Revolution
which said that a thing can only be true
if it could be demonstrably proven true
if it could be historically proven to be
true that's what true means now
that definition of true did not exist in
the ancient mind right true had nothing
to do with facts
true had a much deeper meaning the truth
of the the Nativity Story is that Jesus
was born in the city of Bethlehem
because that's the city of David and
Jesus is the new David and he is going
to recreate the kingdom of David and so
therefore he has to be born in Bethlehem
when everyone knew he was born in
Nazareth his name was the Nazarene
that's what his name was
so you know it's it's only we in the
modern world that have created this kind
of fake uh and totally unnecessary
filter
through which we force all of our
scriptures the Quran the the the Torah
the the gospels all of our scriptures to
uh succumb to our particular definition
of what is true without realizing that
that definition of true is barely 200
years old and are you saying that the
same rules apply to the Torah and also
the Quran All gospel so it's all
metaphorical what we call gospels are
what we refer to as sacred history and
we use that term sacred history
specifically to differentiate it from
actual history and by the way that is
not to denigrate sacred history it's to
understand it for what it actually is
right there's a message that is being
given to us over thousands of years and
that message is important but you have
to filter out the modern conceptions of
how we understand you know facts and
truths in order to actually really get
to the heart of what that message is
last question on this
would most religious Scholars tend to
believe with what you're saying or
because I'm sure there's a large sect of
religious Scholars and people of Faith
whether it's Muslim Jewish Christian of
every sect that'll say sorry Reza this
is the literal word of God and thank you
for your opinion but I'm sticking to the
exactly what the Bible says so there's
people of faith and then there's
religious Scholars how do those two come
to terms with what you're saying well
among religious Scholars what I just
said is the most basic element like fact
number one the thing you learn on day
one right be nothing nothing else that
you do
can happen until you understand that
basic fact that it's metaphorical well
that it's sacred history right so you
can use figurative language metaphorical
language you can extract history from
sacred history there are ways that we
can do that like we can look at the
gospels and say these are the things
that are most likely to be traced to the
actual historical Jesus and these are
the things not and there are
centuries of methodologies that we can
use to rely on to get a very accurate
picture of the difference between the
two
people of Faith No no people of faith
do not think in those terms right for
people of Faith the scripture is God
breathed it's divinely inspired and if
it comes from God then it must be
perfect in all ways and so
what does historical context have to do
with it right Jesus is literally God
speaking to all Humanity so who cares
where he lived who he was actually
speaking to what the political and
economic situation of the world in which
he lived and how it shaped him what does
that matter he has no context God has no
context
right okay so we just for three decades
he lived in first century Palestine
irrelevant irrelevant he's not talking
to his fellow Jews he's talking to you
and me so context has to be stripped
from scripture for it to matter and
Scholars say the opposite so so I I have
a Direction I want to go but I don't
want to go off this topic on until
everybody here is comfortable moving
away from this topic it's within this
topic but I want to go to a different
place do you have something to say Tom
yeah I think there's a couple things
here and
um I think you're taking a very
Academia has done a very good job I
think of um or I don't know if it's a
good job it's been very effective at you
know driving down through the elements
the elements of history and finding what
they claim and believe maybe be are
errors of interpretation or
misunderstanding of historical context
at the time you know you're talking
about the synoptic gospels Matthew Mark
Luke and John you have a tax collector
Matthew you have a a an early World
physician in Luke you have a a student a
Jewish student that almost became a
rabbi and John and then you have just
kind of the common Jewish Man Mark and
so they all are slightly different and
what what surprised me is is you
approaching it and saying geez is that
there is a Jesus man and Jesus Christ
and this was where you went from I would
have supposed a Baptist or Methodist
um uh youth group at least you were
describing it yeah Evangelical what
non-denominational non-denom Community
Church American Community Church
movement from 1980s right is what you're
describing so it's pre-mega church and
it's pre-secret sensitive and it's the
pre you know self-identified Christian
adopting all of the you know um you know
World influences into their into their
their now diluted biblical worldview
okay so you commented that you know
Jesus had no concerns of this world and
the things about equality I think he was
I think it was very consistent even in
um Roman historical writings that his
message was you're equal in that
you all have one you you owe this Earth
One death and you have a soul and that
that was sort of the table Stakes for
everybody yet there was inequality in
classes and cultures and how people were
treated and discriminated against and
things like that but I think Jesus was
very clear that he started there it says
hey you have one Soul you know this
Earth One death and then to say there's
no concerns of this world you know he
was I think very very clear he said
listen you know religion that God our
Father finds faultless and true is this
take care of widows and orphans in their
distress so there is not a socialist but
there is a charity there so I'm kind of
curious as to where
you go from a non-denominational
upbringing through the lens of uh the
three universities that have decidedly
different Catholic approaches which
we're talking about Boston College Notre
Dame and Santa Clara they're very
different you have the literalization
you have the Jesuits correct and that
was your college experience but I think
somewhere between the two it it kind of
feels to me that I'm I'm just trying to
figure out
how you bridge from that to the college
perspective and the college perspective
was the Catholic Church which was an
inversion the first century Catholic
Church people thought Peter was the
first pope not correct historically or
nodding yes
um found to be and then that created a
government church so the Catholic church
was nothing more than some Christian
tenants applied to to basically Rome
built in the middle of Rome
how odd and then enabling the monarchies
of the 14th 15th 16th centuries to do a
bunch of things and so I I just I just
think you've got several islands here
you kind of go to and I was just trying
to find the thread that led you to say
okay
you know what I am no longer
a Christian by okay flawed man needs a
path to Heaven that path is the perfect
Christ to give a sacrifice for me I was
trying to figure out in your description
what that stepping off point
well um first I should mention that I
went to Santa Clara and then I went to
Harvard and Santa Barbara not the not uh
Notre Dame or no no but I'm I'm using
the other yeah I'm well aware of the
threat of of the threat of teaching that
goes from Jesuit Boston College Notre
Dame and Santa Clara and they're very
different interpretations and are very
different delusions that happens in
academic Academia and you were a student
at Santa Clara so that's that's what you
have been hosed off with no absolutely
here's I think the sort of the most
basic way of answering a very complex
question
the sort of foundational view about
Jesus amongst the most mainstream
Christianity is that he was fully man
and fully God right that's the that's
the great mystery of the Incarnation
that he was 100 man and he was 100 God
the problem with Christianity especially
the way that it was introduced to me
is that it ignored the man part
or when it did focus on the man part it
was simply to buttress
the god part right that's that's the
only reason that you talked about Jesus
being thirsty or Jesus being uh tortured
what was the word you just used I've
never heard that before it buttressed
his his Divine like it was there just to
support his div his divinity right he
was a man we can talk about him as a man
but only in so far as talking about him
as a man makes the fact that he's God
that much more extraordinary right like
look at the things that he did when in
fact he was God you guys
[Music]
what I wanted to do
was say okay it's fully man fully god
let's remove the god part from the
equation for a minute and let's actually
deal with the consequences of what it
means to say he was fully man
because if he's fully man
he lived in a very specific time and
place
he was like all human beings a product
of that time and place it shaped who he
was it shaped how we spoke when he spoke
he wasn't speaking into the ether
he was speaking to someone in front of
him he had an audience in front of him
so who was that audience and what was
that audience like and what was that
audience expecting
when he used certain words to speak with
them had other people use those words
what did those words actually mean when
Jesus said the kingdom of God is on
Earth or the kingdom of God is in you or
the kingdom of God is coming
his audience had heard the phrase
kingdom of God a million times
so
as a scholar
you can't say with any confidence what
Jesus meant by the kingdom of God unless
you know what his audience meant by the
phrase kingdom of God
and what his audience meant what his
audience heard what Jesus meant when he
said those words was a new world order
because right now the king is Caesar
if I'm to re-establish the kingdom of
God which is the sole function of the
Messiah in the Hebrew Bible you have one
job if you're a messiah and that's to
recreate the kingdom of David the
kingdom of God
well you can't recreate the kingdom of
David when sitting on top of it is the
kingdom of Rome
so
without question
every Jew every poor impoverished
Village Jew because that's all he ever
spoke to
who heard the phrase kingdom of God
heard Liberation from Rome every single
one of them
so when we as Scholars look at Jesus
preaching about the kingdom of God we
understand that what he is preaching is
Liberation from Rome
when we as religious people 2000 years
removed from all the history and context
and as people who stop even thinking
about Jesus as a human being a product
of his time and place someone you know
privy to context but as an ethereal
Eternal Everlasting ghostly Celestial
being with no context whatsoever who
isn't talking to impoverished Jews he's
talking to you and me
kingdom of God means something
completely different has nothing to do
with the liberation of Rome and so we
strip Jesus's words
of all of its complexity its politics
its historical context we spiritualize
it and in spiritualizing it it does
something very very useful to Patrick's
Point it does something very very useful
which is that it now becomes the
foundation of Empire
this isn't talking about this world he's
talking about the next world
so you can do whatever the [ __ ] you want
to in this world right you know the the
first will be last the last will be
first well that's in heaven
not on this Earth I don't have to worry
about that I don't have to worry about
any of the implications of this radical
teaching that resulted in him being
hunted down like a rebel
arrested by the state and executed for
treason
you know like let's let's just
acknowledge that for a moment right I
mean you don't get executed for treason
because you're like be like the birds of
this of the sky
don't worry about the things of this
world that's not how you get executed
for treason I can fully appreciate by
the way what you're saying
distinguishing between the man and God
and I know Tom as a man of deep faith
and I'm sure he wants to ask you a
question I just one specific question
that you brought up you said he was only
talking to Jews
and I just want you to just hone in on
that for a second uh two-part question
was it only Jews around him straight up
and then number two in your expert
opinion did Jesus mean to start a new
religion the most important thing the
most important fact to understand about
Jesus when trying to figure out who he
was and what he was talking about is
that he was a Jew preaching Judaism to
other Jews this was not a new religion
there was nothing new about what he was
preaching it was Judaism and he was
preaching it in Jewish terms he was
preaching it in Aramaic was he speaking
Hebrew Aramaic what was Hebrew was was
an educated uh language so he may have
he may have understood Hebrew when it
was spoken like when if someone read the
the Hebrew scriptures he could have he
probably could have understood it but he
wouldn't communicate in Hebrew he would
communicate in Aramaic which is the
language of the poor
um and he was speaking to other poor
Jews he was a poor Jew preaching Judaism
to other poor Jews
once you understand that that and that's
not disputed right that's that's sort of
a very basic understanding of of the
gospels once you understand that then it
opens a door to understanding what it is
that he's actually saying how would
these poor Jews understand these words
he's not talking to you he's not talking
to me right he's not he's not preaching
Christianity
he was a Jew preaching Judaism what was
so radical about what he was preaching
to Jews because you've used that word he
was a radical he was right you know he
was he had all these crazy ideas but if
he was preaching Judaism to other Jews
what was so radical about that well
Judaism like all religions comes in a
hundred different flavors right right
we've already talked about it with
Catholicism uh the Judaism of first
century Palestine had a bunch of
different flavors there was the temple
Judaism the Judaism that was controlled
by the Jewish authorities that was
involved that involved very uh
restrictive extraordinarily expensive
Temple uh rituals that all Jews were
forced uh to do at least once a year if
not more
and that was a business it was a it was
a business decision governed by the
Parish government governed by the
Pharisees yeah and the Sadducees and
they and they controlled the temple and
since the temple was the source of
Salvation they controlled salvation
right if they could tell you that you
were a Jew or not a Jew right because
they controlled the thing where God
literally dwelled
then there was this sort of pharisaic
Judaism which eventually becomes what we
know as rabbinic Judaism right the the
the the Judaism of the law right the
scholars the thinkers The Debaters and
that like as you can imagine ran the
gamut right very conservative
views much more sort of innovative
interpretations of the Torah and the law
and then there were thousands upon
thousands of charismatic Street
Preachers like Jesus many of whom call
themselves Messiah many many oh yes yes
yes yes we know I say in in Zealot we
know the names of at least 12. if we
know the names of at least 12 then there
were 1200
um of people who said that they were the
Messiah people who said they were the
Messiah who led Messianic movements who
had far far more followers than Jesus
ever did
um and all of whom so here's what I want
to do Tom do you have any questions back
or rebuttals back because I want to go a
different direction right now yeah maybe
maybe it's time we just go to different
okay so here's what I'm going to say to
you so question for you do you believe
um
uh the story of Virgin birth Mary what
are your thoughts like Do You Believe In
The credibility of that story do I
believe it's a fact or do I believe it's
truth do do you believe well what's the
difference that's the key okay so is
what's the fact a fact is a thing can't
be debated right a fact is a thing that
can be scientifically verified okay
right that's that's what we Now
understand a truth it doesn't
necessarily have to do with fact truth
is a far deeper well both ways what do
you think about it no there's there's no
fact whatsoever about the Virgin birth
it exists in one section of the entire
uh uh gospels okay
um no one else mentions it uh Matthew
doesn't mention it it's just Justin Luke
uh that means 90 A.D so 60 years after
Jesus's death we can go back to the
writings that we find you know a little
bit earlier there's some writings of
Paul in in 50s virgin birth is never
mentioned in those in those writings
this was the Virgin birth was a problem
that arose out of Paul
because Paul who never met Jesus never
spoke to Jesus had nothing to do with
Jesus whatsoever but who claims to have
had this experience of the Risen Jesus
long after
um Jesus died in which uh according to
him Jesus makes him the sort of the 13th
Apostle right an apostle was somebody
who walked and talked with Jesus and
there were 12 of them and Paul who
neither walked nor talked with Jesus
says that that the Risen Christ turned
him into the 13th Apostle and gave him
this new message
and Paul goes around and he starts
preaching this version of Jesus that the
apostles
had never heard of before Jesus wasn't
even a man in Paul's view Jesus was born
of pure light he is a new genus of being
he came to Earth as this sort of
begotten the the only begotten Son of
God in order to uh to deal with original
sin again Jesus never mentioned anything
about original sin it's not in any of
the gospels and Paul's imagination when
Adam and Eve fell all human beings were
born in sin and Jesus's death
cleared that sin for everyone for all of
time this is Paul has no one except Paul
had ever said or thought anything like
this it was the first time these words
were ever written it's now basic
Christianity but here's the problem
if everyone who is born is born of sin
until Jesus is born and rids everyone of
sin then Jesus can't be born
Paul himself never said Jesus can't be
born he just let the contradiction live
but then later on
by the time you get to the 90s
in answer to to criticism an answer to
critics saying wait a minute what are
you talking about like then doesn't make
any sense he himself was born then he
had sin was this new idea that no no
Jesus wasn't born in the in the same way
he was born of a virgin it's mentioned
once it's mentioned in the year 90. and
there's no reason to think that it's
anything other than what it sounds like
an answer to a problem
so so in other words for you your
interpretation is that that's just a
fictional story that's being told about
it's it's sacred history but the same
can be said about Quran the same thing
can be said about all the books that's
right and that's what you're saying so
in in other words all the books just to
be fair
if from your point and you see yourself
as an atheist or you're a Muslim oh no
no I'm I'm a Muslim I'm a person of
Faith sure your personal faith you so
you believe in Prophet Muhammad you
believe in his book you believe in Quran
I don't believe in Quran again that's
the wrong way of putting it these are
not things to believe in they are
signposts to the thing to believe in
scripture as sacred history is the
attempt by individuals who have
confronted an extraordinary
extraordinary experience
and who have using the limited means at
their disposal
attempted to record that
extraordinary experience often in Poetic
and symbolic language deep meaningful
mystical language so that they can
preserve it for generations to
understand well you're also metaphase so
you're also a man of Faith okay so to
you your the risk you're taking is I'm
risking believing the Quran not the
Bible that's your risk right I mean
faith is believing in something you have
not yet seen there's a lot of criticism
on the book of Quran there's a lot of
criticism on the Muslim religion a lot
of criticism on the religion you
represent your risk is I think after
life is my bet is I'm going to take the
route of uh uh being a Muslim versus I
see where you're coming yeah I'm sorry
when you study the religions of the
world
it becomes impossible to take any one of
these religions all that seriously and
there's two reasons for it one because
you instantly recognize the religious
patterns the sort of a phenomena that
they all have in common with each other
that they're all saying basically the
same thing and more importantly they're
saying it kind of in the same way right
A lot of the same myths are just kind of
repurposed the myth of Jesus's
resurrection is just the myth of mithras
Resurrection right the shraushant in uh
in Zoroastrianism is a salvific
character uh whose mother magically gets
impregnated and gives birth to a
Messianic figure who brings in the end
of the world that's a thousand years
before Jesus right I mean these are just
the same stories over and over and over
again
however
they are interlinked
in the sense that they are trying to
express something that as a person of
faith I believe is real
and that is that there is something
beyond the material realm there is a
real Transcendent reality beyond the
physical world but it's faith faith it's
so it's a risk it's absolutely okay so
the risk so there's a part of me that's
sitting here listening to you for the
first hour
you sound more atheist than you sound
muslim okay you sound more atheist you
definitely don't sound Christian
obviously you're given the arguments of
atheists it's like I'm listening to uh
uh Chris Hitchens debate his brother
uh uh or I'm listening to an atheist
give their argument that's the part so
that kind of comes back to saying well
why do you choose to be a Muslim why do
you choose to follow the Quran if you're
such a scholar and you're educated and
you got these four degrees shouldn't an
educated man like yourself who's dealing
a lot on facts not risk believing any
religion and rather just be an atheist
you are you a minute ago you just said
that when you look at any of the world
religions that there's there's flaws and
there's issues and they and there's
lunacies and then there's repeated myths
so how did you choose one rather than
just being a very scholar of the fake
question yeah say hey I'm the scholar of
the fake here's all my books I'm going
to delve into certain characters
Baskerville and others like this
but you know what no I'm going to stop
and I'm going to choose one how do you
get there so yeah this is a great
question first of all let's try to rid
our minds of these categories like
atheist Muslim well if you're you're
clearly not a Christian because you
question certain aspects of the Bible
[ __ ] there are hundreds of millions
of Christians who would agree with
everything that I just said and would I
mean priests the priests who taught me
these things right they're not just
Christians they've given their life
they're dedicated their entire life
things are weird hope is saying certain
things right now that the Catholic
Church wouldn't have agreed with 20
years ago but and Catholics
unfortunately have to be are forced to
agree with them not forced just because
well because he's not going to
excommunicate when I say forced if you
want to be part of the church and the
Pope says it oh my God I'm either gonna
have to leave my rituals that I've been
living for the last 48 years and go be a
non-denominational go be something else
or just say defend the pope just to be
clear that's only if the pope uh
threatens uh this communication if the
Pope says this is now belief and if you
don't believe it then you are
excommunicated then yes you're forced to
believe it but the pope doesn't do any
of that stuff and the pope is Christian
and so if he's not of not of not a
different kind of a Christian today than
20 or 30 years ago okay there is no such
thing as Christianity let's start there
there is no such thing as Islam there is
no such thing as Judaism there is no
such thing as Buddhism there is only
Christianity's buddhisms Islams
Christianity is whatever a Christian
says it is Buddhism is whatever a
Buddhist says it is there is no
mechanism for me to say you call
yourself a Buddhist okay but you don't
believe this interpretation of the
person is what you're saying you're not
really a Buddhist so let's let's start
there that's the important thing the
second thing that I think is really
important to understand is that religion
all religions
are far less a matter of beliefs and
practices than they are a matter of
identity and that's true of every
religion in the world and every part of
the world seventy percent of Americans
call themselves Christian [ __ ]
[ __ ] 70 of Americans follow the
teachings of Christ seventy percent of
Americans go to church on you know
Sunday seventy percent of Americans read
the Bible on a consistent basis the vast
majority of that 70 when they say I am
Christian they are not making a faith
statement they're making an identity
statement and that is true of it
Buddhists and Jews and Muslims that what
we people on the outside tend to do is
think that religion is just about the
things that you believe and if you don't
believe what the mainstream believes
then you're not really that thing
anymore I don't disagree with that I'm
with you there on the identity party
to the question there's some
fundamentals here right and when if if a
person says I'm a Muslim or a person
says I'm a Christian you you dive into
it a little bit and you
more often than not you're going to find
some world view creep in where they've
made their own designation when you take
a look at the 70 of people in America
that say they're a Christian there's
only about 15 percent of those that have
what you would call a Biblical worldview
and these are not the Amish in the
middle of Pennsylvania adopting nothing
of modern technology these are people
that have an authentic biblical
worldview and at the same thing there's
people that say well I'm Jewish well now
wait a minute are you a Zionist as a
political State Jew or are you authentic
so I think identity is like you're
correct about it but we need to kind of
wash that a little bit because I can say
I'm a southerner oh sorry sorry listen
I'm I'm sorry I'm a Bostonian what is a
Bostonian I'm sorry I'm a New Englander
we have all these labels do you know
what we just kind of take it as it is
I'm a midwesterner right you have all
labels that happen all over the place
and you can't take a broad brush and
just sweep everything out Reza because
you're correct about the 70 you are
correct about the 70 percent
he said but within that there are people
that do have a Biblical worldview
whether they be Jews whether they be
Muslims whether they be Christians there
are those are they the real Christians
because they have the biblical worldview
and and the other 45 aren't I think well
you know what a cleric would tell you
that it is my job and I'll speak to your
faith that it is my job to ensure that I
teach and I help people to calibrate
what is the authenticity of their Muslim
faith and the principles and tendency
and who
gave him that job
he went to school and he learned a bunch
of things and now well he also has he
also has the scripture that they have
and he can either choose I have that
same scripture that's exactly right you
can be north of London and you can be a
radical cleric what I don't want to do
the two what I don't want to do is the
following here's what I don't want to do
and by the way there's there's angles I
can take with Virgin Mary in the Quran
and what uh you know the Quran says
about Virgin Mary and what mus many
Muslims think about Virgin Mary and we
can go that angle but the part I was
going to go with you on the Virgin Mary
side that even in the Quran they talk
about is the chances of somebody being
born because you know a lot of people
made that claim back in the days because
it's embarrassing oh my God you know
you're having sex on you know prior to
this prior to getting married
and then for the chances of that sun
ending up being Jesus that's a one in a
trillion type of a number that's just a
very random method I'm a math guy very
random mathematical number to come up
with that so the faith part with that is
it's tough to kind of fight against that
part but let me let me come back because
the question was still not answered yeah
let me let me come back to the question
so if your arguments I'm listening to
you
you're very critical of the Christian
church in a very non-critical way the
way you're doing it is a a way a scholar
would do it uh where
uh the the average person listens to
that and they say oh my God what do I
say to this part here but I'll flip it
and I'll say dude you sound like an
atheist and I can respect that if you're
an atheist you're an atheist if you're
gonna say look my risk on taking a life
I'm taking a risk that quran's the book
I'm not taking a risk that I'm going to
be a Christian I'm taking the original
I'm going to be a Muslim no problem
let's get past this part I'm going to go
to the next part on question if you want
to answer the atheist spot you will
answer it as well here in a minute but
here's what I want you to be thinking
about
um how do you judge a great parent
how do you judge a great parent by their
actions
by their actions Yeah by how they raise
their the things that they do that's how
I judge every person okay things that
you do is it fair for me to judge you
based on
like if I see you
my imagination I've never met your mom
I've never met your dad this is our
first interaction to get us to the
audience and we've never had dinner
together I don't know your story except
for what I've read right
I see a part of you that's your dad and
I see a part of you that's your mom I
see the rebel in your dad okay where
he's a rebellious guy and he's I see the
atheist arguments of your dad when I'm
listening to you okay but then I see
also your loyalty for your mom's side
and then your own independence where I'm
gonna go take my ride and here's what I
come up with listen Mom Dad salute you
on this side pop salute to your mom on
this side my dad never fails to remind
me that Romania was a big mistake he
called it right you talk about that
regularly
but if we're going to judge a product
based on its parents
product parents parents good job you
raise a good citizen he's done well for
himself right
I think it's also fair to judge a
religion based on what it produces okay
based on what it produces so let's let's
go away from uh uh I've sat and debated
with guys who know every single
scripture in the Bible but nobody
follows them they're very small and I've
sat and talked to people that are
generalists who have a lot of people
that follow them because of their
messaging this is not a debate of we
would need two days to go through
scripture said this and what's your
rebuttal to this and what about this and
what about that we'll be here for days
two hours is not enough yeah
but if we were to judge a religion based
on what it produces
if
had the choice to choose a country and
you can't say none you have to choose
one if you were to say
you know a a countries we're starting a
country together what religion would we
want to start it with what religion
would best be a good religion to be
that's a fun question they want to start
a country with that's a really fun I'm
curious okay so let me answer the first
part I feel like I I left you hanging
because you ask a professor a question
he has like 40 minutes of Prelude to it
but to just get to it
I am not an atheist because I think
atheism is an intellectually vacuous
position
I think it's unsophisticated I don't
think it's smart
an atheist a true atheist right someone
who is truly an atheist is a materialist
a materialist believes that literally
nothing exists that nothing can exist
beyond my empirical experience of that
thing
that to me is the height of hubris and
absurdity right the idea that all that
exists is the material realm and nothing
Beyond it is just I would say even
scientifically absurd
now what is that other thing who knows
okay just let's just give it a word
because that's all the word God is it's
just a word it's not a thing it's a word
and like all words it has a thousand
connotations it represents a bunch of
things but in its simplest form let's
just say what we mean when we say God is
that which is beyond that which is
beyond the material realm the thing
the question then becomes can I access
that thing do I have the ability to
commune with it to communicate with it
to experience it in some way
and that's a personal thing I've
accessed it I've communicated with it
I've experienced it people who do yoga
people who climb mountains people who
surf and yes people who are Christians
or Jews or Muslims or Buddhists or
whatever can tell you a very similar
story yeah I'm not going to prove this
intellectually all I can tell you is
that there is something Beyond and I
have touched it I have felt it so then
the next question is do I want to know
it
was it enough that I climbed that
mountain and was like Wow and then I
went back home or do I want to know it
now
well if you want to know it
it so happens that there are a lot you
know thousands of years worth of systems
languages that's what really religion is
all about it's just languages languages
are made up of symbols of and metaphors
that help you experience communicate
that experience make sense of that
experience
and you can pick any language you want
it is irrelevant what language you
choose just different symbols like
saying what's better French or German
what are you talking about they're both
expressing the exact same thing just
pick one
the Buddha very famously said
if you want to strike water you don't
dig six one foot Wells you dig one six
foot well
Islam is my six foot well
but the important thing that's hidden in
the Buddha's words there is that the
well is irrelevant the well is nothing
more than the means to get to the water
and guess what the water that you're
drinking from is the water that every
well is drinking from so pick a well
pick a well that works for you
in my case for a whole host of reasons
my culture my background my identity my
comfort Islam is my six foot well
and particularly Sufi Islam is my six
foot well it's the language that I use
to make sense of a thing that is
inexpressible
it's a it's a language I use to talk
about a thing that's impossible to talk
about
and it's a language that other people
understand so I can communicate with
them they get it we can talk about that
experience
but to say that I believe in the well is
stupid people who say I believe in
Christianity I believe in Islam I
believe in the Quran I believe in the
Torah are doing it wrong those are not
things to believe in they're your well
they're the thing that points you to the
thing to believe in
and so as someone who wants a deep and
meaningful spiritual life uh who has
experienced Transcendence and wants to
experience it more and understand it
more I've chosen this particular well
which is your risk we've taken risk
everybody's second day The Atheist takes
a risk the Christian takes a risk now
okay yeah so so let me preface questions
with the audience this is Jesus has a
clip we could start a new country which
religion would be the best religion to
start the country on which religion
would be the best religion to start a
new country
um
oh
this is a really really good question
because on the one hand no religion has
a monopoly on Democracy the idea that
democracy fits better with like
Christianity than it does with Islam is
demonstrably false
um
but
the the one big advantage of
Christianity
is that it has fully and completely
married itself to capitalism
and so if you were going to start a
country
that re that required economic success
capitalism is the right way to do it so
I would say yeah probably some kind of
protestant some kind of protestant
version of Christianity would be a great
start but I will say one thing
democracy true liberal democracy isn't
dependent on secularism secularism does
not a democracy make
imperialism is what makes democracy the
whole point of a democracy is that
individuals get to vote on things based
on their own personal ideas and beliefs
and whether you like it or not for the
vast majority of humans on Earth their
personal beliefs and identities are
enrapt around religious identity so to
say that religion should not have a role
to play in democracy means that there's
no democracy that's what that means
the question is can you have the proper
safeguards in place to make sure that
people who do not adhere to that
majority religion or or to religion at
all are equally protected from having
their rights infringed upon by the
religion of the majority that's what the
United States was supposed to be with
the the you know anti-establishment
Clause uh but you know we are 350
million people
of which
150 million of us are right-wing
Evangelical Christians who believe that
the country is a Christian Nation and
should be based on Christian principles
and laws and that non-christians would
have a a a a sort of
secondary role you know as second-class
Citizens in that kind of country well
that's legit that's like half the
country that's a serious threat so all
religion can threaten Democratic
institutions but if I were to start all
over again and it had to be founded on a
religious tradition I think I'd probably
pick Protestants so in other words
you're a capitalist Protestant who
chooses to argue socialist Muslim what a
strange life that's about that's about
right so listen man the way the way I
want everything to be is a Protestant
capitalist because
do you know first of all I appreciate
you for being honest because you know
you could have taken that and
manipulated it and taken many different
angles to kind of make the argument
better for you but you took the argument
and just straight up said what you
wouldn't what would make you feel safer
why didn't you say Muslim why Why not
start a country and it being based on
Islam Muslim being the original
foundations of the country again so
Islams right there are multiple multiple
and a socialist why not create a country
based on you know like the
judeo-christian no we're going to be
Muslim we're going to follow Prophet
Muhammad we're going to fight we're
gonna have a socialist Nation why don't
you start a nation based on I would also
excise the phrase judeo-christian from
your language right away that's a
[ __ ] phrase invented by white
Protestants in order to in order to to
to bring Jews into the fold no Jew uses
the term judeo-christian
um and and the the
the contradiction between those terms is
hilarious the the whole point of
Christianity is that there's no more
need for Judaism because one Jew said so
um so it's just judeo-christian is just
this bizarre fake term to basically mean
white that's what it means it means
White
um stop using it
um uh you just triggered my friend over
here wait what was the question I'm
sorry so so yeah you know how I got true
you know how America is built on a
judeo-christian okay why not start your
country where America is built on
protestantism let's be very very Quran
Prophet Muhammad actually socialism tell
me
now when you go when you go back and
take a look
um basically the founding father is
radius more than anything else deism is
a form of protestantism
um deism is protestantism that's what it
is I I think if you want it to be it can
be if it helps your argument it can be
but I when you hear people saying well
you know go take a look at the things
that are at the Lincoln Memorial and the
Jefferson Memorial and I've heard that
over and over and over again in various
speakers
um we're Christian pastors there are no
scriptures carved in those things there
are none and as a matter of fact it was
Thomas Jefferson who built and as a
scholar you probably know this you know
the Virginia the Virginia religious
Clause where he listed everybody and he
used the word infidels because he
thought that all people should be
protected in America to have the freedom
freedom of of expression but this was a
these were deist that applied certain
things you look at Jefferson goes back
to France before he gets his writings
Hamilton came from Perkins Croy right
but all of these come together the deism
that may have been influenced by
Christianity but first and foremost they
they were deist not Protestant pastors
but no they're not pastors they're not
religious Scholars nor were they nor are
they Protestant Scholars but
they weren't Protestant skull they
weren't Scholars at all but what this
argument that you hear all the time that
you know the founding fathers were
deists is a absolutely correct and deism
is a movement that arises out of
protestantism the primary purpose of
protestantism is to say that we don't
need an institution to interpret the
scripture for us we can interpret it on
our own that means we value the
scripture we don't we don't think the
scripture is is false or unnecessary
it's just that I don't need an
intermediary between me and the
scripture to tell you what it means
hence Thomas Jefferson pulled out his
scissors and said I don't like this
verse and you just cut it out I don't
like this section and he cut it out
deism isn't some brand new religion
invented by the founding fathers it is a
natural progression from protestantism
and it's thousands of thousands of sects
from Quakers to Shakers to methodists to
Baptists deists were just one of the
many many many
uh uh interpretations that arose we can
move on and disagree because deism has
such roots and basically all men seek
that when you find Native Americans that
they encountered when they Iroquois when
they first came here they said isn't it
interesting that the Iroquois seemed to
seek this Creator this God and sometimes
it's wrath the sun god of the Egyptians
sometimes it's other things deism I
thought had a true ten all men seek not
in it and recognizing men meaning all
civilizations all living humans
ultimately are seeking isn't it
interesting when we encounter them that
they have their way of seeking this this
thing this Creator whatever they want to
call to move on to them we can move on
to them so going back to it so if if
America is a judeo-christian nation okay
I'm gonna keep saying that
so for you why not start a country based
on the Quran following Prophet Muhammad
and socialism
well I think the uh the like I said it
was the the issue of capitalism that I
think is the big is the biggest
capitalist I mean we're all capitalists
man look at you you're a capitalist
we're all capital I'm a proud capitalist
I don't know if you're a proud
capitalist I will I will go I'm uh I'm a
moral capitalist I do not believe in the
Invisible Hand of the free market if
that's what you're asking so you're I
don't I don't worship the Invisible Hand
I don't know the difference between a
capitalist and a moral capitalist you're
talking criminals that's what you're
talking about I mean I'm with you it's
like saying I believe when when people
say I I don't believe in uh uh uh
pedophilia within the churches and what
you think I believe in them I guess so
so of course I support moral capitalism
no but so you're a capitalist I bet I
bet that you have a almost religious
like faith in the power of the free
market to set its own uh agendas and
regulations and limitations and that if
you just leave it alone it will take
care of it'll take care I used to until
I study China okay I used to until I
study China because when I started China
and I realized in the 80s they only had
four law schools and it was a doggy dog
type of an environment you start
realizing you need Law and Order and
some regulation it's the over regulation
I have a challenge with where the bigger
companies use lobbyists and politicians
that are broke to buy them to create
laws to make it tougher for the smaller
guy to compete with them that's the
problem I was just chronic yeah that's
what I would say um
I will say the one thing that I've
always read about Twitter is going to
Trend today saying Reza asan said he's a
hardcore capitalist exactly I'm no
longer on Twitter so I couldn't give a
[ __ ]
um uh the uh why are you no longer on
Twitter I I uh deactivated all of my
social media accounts as well as part of
my oh it's by your choice so you're not
on you're not in the penalty box or
something no no I um it was part of my
uh my kind of my New Year's uh
resolution to my wife although I did
four days ago no I actually I did it
early I did it in November right I I
went a little bit early as soon as as
soon as musk was like I'm letting Trump
back on I was like all right that's
enough for me so I was that the trigger
point I mean I was gonna do it January
1st
uh as part of my New Year's resolution
but I was like [ __ ] I'll do it
November 19th do you believe that I know
we're going off topic here but I'm not
going to get the questions answered I
swear to God I got 30 minutes left you
guys keep taking things different
directions you constantly here this is
the third time I'm trying to get a
questions answered yeah well you brought
it up so no I was the way that is
Twitter then you went with a question
about Twitter
Mario the Ayatollah of Iran should be on
Twitter but Donald Trump should not
I I don't think the Ayatollah Iran
should be on Twitter
no but he is
yeah Trump was off
well again Trump is an insurrectionist
who tried to destroy American democracy
and uses his Twitter to to uh actively
promote violence actively promote
violence against his enemies there's no
room in on Twitter for someone like that
doesn't the Ayatollah do the same thing
but much worse well the the Ayatollah is
on Twitter in charge of a fascist a
religious fascist regime that murders
children and uses his Twitter account uh
in order to promote propaganda and lies
about what he's doing he doesn't belong
on Twitter yeah why would he still be on
them what actually the [ __ ] don't worry
I don't know guys I think it's very
important to realize like where he's at
he's saying neither should be on his
position it's better to ask her why do
you not believe both should be on then
why how many how many go back to your
question so I'm going to stay on this
question guys go go ahead because I got
30 minutes before I get on my Max 7 call
so okay so why not start a country based
on socialism Muslim book of Quran I will
say the one thing the one thing that I
that I do I'm fascinated by Islamic
Finance right this idea uh and Jewish
Finance is the same way that the the
prohibition against interest and usury
that there are ways to do that that are
that and and there have been a number of
very successful ways of doing this where
um the way that it works is that instead
of loaning someone money to start a
business you invest in that business and
so there isn't any interest that you're
owed but you are owed dividends from the
uh from the business that's how most
Islamic financing things work and the
idea there being that hey we're all in
this together it's not like I loaned you
a hundred thousand dollars your business
collapsed too bad where's my money
um
but like most things it has been
absolutely infected by Western
capitalism so that you can say we're not
charging interest and so therefore
staying islamically compliant but this
investment comes with fees
that are essentially interest and that
make it very very difficult for these
small businesses to actually function if
you want to start I mean I would took
your question very very literally like
I'm starting a country from scratch
right which requires an enormous amount
of economic stability and build up how
would I do that well I would need
capitalism and
Islam is not exactly conducive to
capitalism neither is Judaism
but protestantism
it's it's not just conducive to
capitalism it is capitalism radical
individualism you have been in in not
all protestantism uh but like in
calvinist Evangelical you know
Presbyterian uh uh protestantism you've
already been predestined you've been
prejudged to be successful if you have
money it's because God likes you that's
why if you don't have money it's well
you should really look at yourself and
figure out why
um those are you know immoral ways of
thinking about money but if I'm starting
a country from scratch
right and I want this thing to last yeah
I'd probably start with a good dose of
protestantism how about now that
everything's established raising your
kids you got three sons okay three sons
and a daughter yeah oh you have a
daughter okay it only says three sons
you gotta updated yeah pandemic
congratulations to you thank you we also
have four kids two two but going back to
it now that you have the kids it's
different to start versus where you want
to be once you have a family yeah why
not raise your family your kids in a in
a Muslim Nation rather than in the U.S
you have a choice right now just like
your mom and dad chose to say let's get
out of here let's go to a different
place I know your wife's a Christian so
you could say well my wife is a
Christian so it'd be tough to go to a
different place but why choose to raise
your kids in a judeo-christian
country like America why do that to
yourself why put yourself out of your
misery just go to a different place go
to Indonesia why be here well I don't
first of all I don't know if I would
think about it in those terms about like
you know raising them in a Christian
country as opposed to a Muslim country
as opposed to a Jewish country yeah what
I do is I raise them to be
multi-literate in all the languages all
the religious languages of the world
my kids understand both at a spiritual
level and and at a at an intellectual
level that religion is a language made
up of symbols and metaphors that us
communicating very similar sentiments
what matters is the sentiment I want you
to be spiritual I want you to know that
there is more to life than just what you
feel or smell or taste or see that there
is more and that you can access that
thing you can strive for Transcendence
and use your own means of doing it find
out what's most comfortable for you one
of my sons a few years ago after a very
raucous Rosh Hashanah celebration just
flat out declared himself Jewish was
like this is this is fun this is way
more fun than anything else that I've
done I want to be Jewish now and Rosh
Hashanah celebration yeah I've been to
many Rosh Hashanah celebrations I've
never been like this is the best party
I've ever met all that happens and honey
you could eat come to West Hollywood
buddy he said he said it was raucous one
West Hollywood yo West Hollywood
and uh and you know we a lot because for
everyone a couple of years ago we went
to Israel as a family and the whole time
he was like my people I'm amongst my
people
um I have another son who has uh I
bought him a um a kid's version of the
ramayana
which just blew his mind the idea that
God can be can exist in multiple avatars
and that each Avatar has a different
thing to it like this for strength and
for wisdom and for for power like that
so Hinduism he's all about Hinduism
right now I mean he radically believes
in reincarnation radically believes in
Karma
um I have another kid another boy who
I'm pretty sure is the reincarnated
Buddha but that's a whole different
story and we go to mosque we go to
church we go to synagogue we took our
kids on an 80-day Journey around the
world literally we circled the globe in
80 Days and went to ancient religious
places modern religious places
um it's great you know what's very
important if you want to raise spiritual
kids who aren't religious Fanatics teach
them about all religions they have the
ability in a way that adults whose minds
are fixated to differentiate between a
the external aspects of a religion and
the inter confuse the hell out of them
as your approach on the contrary it
confuses adults it makes perfect sense
to Kit it makes perfect sense to a 10
year old what kind of what kind of stuff
let's go to what kind of school do your
kids I mean they go to a nice private
school but no no look is it Christian as
a Catholic is it a yes
secular so okay got it a 10 year old can
understand
intuitively that the rabbi and the Imam
and the priests are saying the same
thing they're just using different
symbols and the symbols even look kind
of familiar it's we we right here yeah
who can't figure that out like what do
you mean like they're different
religions to say different things they
have different ideas they like they read
different scriptures and you know they
they it's like but are they saying the
same thing though because
like I guess my question is like can all
religions be correct or can only one be
the correct religion remove the idea of
correct and incorrect right and wrong
when talking about religion they are
signposts all religions are signposts to
say that Christianity is more correct
than Islam is to say that French is more
correct than German
what the hell are you talking about it's
the thing that you are expressing
whether you say it in German or whether
you say it in French doesn't make it any
more correct
you're saying it's a means to an end and
the ends to an end okay religion so is
not an independent phenomenon religion
is an amalgamation a collection a system
of ways of thinking about the world many
of which has been constructed over
thousands of years and often very sort
of under control right by institutions
this is what it means and it can't mean
anything else
um yeah but I think that's the problem
is that nobody interprets it like that
like that's actually a great way of
looking at it whether it's like like how
you use the example of I'd rather dig
one six foot
well for to reach the water versus six
one foot Wells I can appreciate that
here's what I would say is you think
that nobody interprets it that way
because people are not as conscious of
it
two thirds of American Catholics
believe uh or disagree with the Catholic
church when it comes to abortion and
lgbtq rights but they call themselves
Catholic but wait a minute abortion
lgbtq those are like fairly set things
in the Catholic church it's like you
believe this if you want to be with us
well I want to be with you but I don't
believe those things
and there's no contradiction there it
doesn't doesn't stay up all night
thinking about these things they don't
write books about it they don't come on
podcasts and talk about what that
actually means for two hours it just is
and that's true for all religious people
I think a lot of unreligious people
people outside of religion
you know the the Dawkins and the
harrises and the and the you know uh
Hitchens believe that religious people
are like automatons right they're like
the old-fashioned
um you know IBM computers right you
remember the the little sheet with the
dots on it and stuff that that's that's
what scripture is that it's like we're
an automaton and the scripture is the
program and the scripture you read the
scripture and it goes and you do the
thing in the scripture that's not how it
works man
that's not how it works scripture
without interpretation is just words on
a page it requires an individual to
encounter it for it to have any meaning
at all and by definition
the minute an individual encounters that
scripture it goes through the filter of
his entire experience his entire
identity and it comes out different on
the other side that's why two people
can go to the exact same scripture and
walk away with two radically different
points of view in American history not
two centuries ago both slave owners and
abolitionists not only use the same
scripture in order to justify their
viewpoints they use the same exact
verses right
that's what scripture you know you know
I got to tell you so a couple things
very interesting point I agree somebody
can go watch a movie and have yesterday
I was telling the kids I said hey how is
it that both of you guys are the same
parents yet you're two completely
opposite people right they're the same
things being taught you're taking two
different messaging there's a part of
that that's correct I have twins so yeah
but there's a part of it as well as on
how
it's being taught messaging received all
of that part of it is on the person's
individual personality you know the
reason why I asked that question about
you know country starting all that other
stuff sometimes we spend time debating
things that is just purely opinion
here's what I think here's what I
believe here's what I think I think that
story there's only one time Paul said
this and to Paul Jesus is this and let
me tell you Prophet Muhammad and this
and marriage and slaves and great got it
you can debate that all you want as
Scholars all that stuff and then you go
to what produces results what provides
the most important uh letter for uh
Mother's uh interests when raising kids
the S award which is security safety a
country that provides that they want to
live there yeah and then for somebody
that's hard working to be able to build
a life that they want to build whatever
their life may be and then for someone
to say hey I don't want the guy to be
able to bully me you know hey this guy's
bigger than me I don't want him to come
and take advantage of me can I be
protected by by the law so Guy cannot
bully me so we need some laws and then
hey the other countries that are
attacking us can we have a decent
military so people just don't want to
fight us let's not have a military to
kill people let's have a military that
prevents others from wanting to fight us
and then at the same time allow me to
have whatever religion and beliefs that
I have leave me alone if I'm a Muslim
leave me alone if I'm this leave me
alone like some people say combination
should be on Twitter and Trump should be
on Twitter your argument is a argument
of no I think both of them should be off
of Twitter my argument maybe I think
both of them should be on Twitter for
somebody to be able to make a decision
and say I can't even believe what Trump
just said I can't believe what common
age just said
I can't believe what Putin just said now
there are some that are inciting let's
go kill let's go do this that's a
different story that's you're breaking
the law that we're talking about let's
go to the last topic that we have here
before we wrap up Iran you and I are
Iranian and uh when I tell a lot of
friends that uh you know Reza's coming
on I had 50 50 split what people say
yeah oh my God let me tell you don't do
it
cause I'm gonna tell you they're gonna
Target you these Muslims you got to be
careful you bring bring call out
Christianity nothing will happen to you
call out Jesus nothing will happen to
you call out scientologists something
may happen to you call out a lot of but
again just one thing you don't go you
know you just don't go yeah it's kind of
like the the movie Tropic Thunder what
does he say you never nobody go full
[ __ ]
the point is you don't ever bring and
argue the Muslim religion and there's
Risk by the way I've brought gangsters
and everybody will say you cross the
line with Muslims they are Fanatics they
will come after etc etc then some of the
people said you know hey let me tell you
the fact that you're bringing them I
think you're gonna enjoy the
conversation you guys are not going to
agree on everything but I think you're
going to enjoy it he's reasonable some
of the stuff he says is crazy but you
can enjoy it which by the way to be fair
I've enjoyed this conversation a lot and
some of the people that know that I'm a
capitalist why would you give this guy a
platform this is my desire I enjoy this
I walk away today saying what a great
way to start the day but the one thing a
lot of the Iranians will will say
they'll say Patrick he's a no Yak he
said no yeah
how can you talk to a person from Nyack
do you realize he represents Iran and he
is a spokesperson for those guys and
they defend and they want the nuclear
deal because it was them that the start
of the nuclear deal go look at the
website who sits on their board Diane
Feinstein Hillary Clinton you know
Kamala Harris all of these guys you have
to be very careful dealing with Nayak
now for people that know who Nayak is
Americans don't say Nayak Americans will
say niac which is what national Iranian
Association of uh Iranian American
Council American Council and so that's
what niec stands for so
you're on the website do you have your
picture no I'm not on the web maybe they
removed you were on the way you're
you're on a website saying that you
supported Nyack I can text it to you and
show it to you on some of the places but
tell me your position with Nyack and
Iran and where you're at [ __ ] about now
okay this whole thing is so stupid well
people are asking just so you know
people are asking because they've been
brainwashed by a by a purposeful
deliberate well-funded well-coordinated
disinformation campaign that seeks to
paint all Progressive Iranian voices as
regime supporters my writing I've
written spoken been on TV I mean I have
two decades of me on television talking
about what I feel about this regime and
what I think needs to happen to it I
have repeatedly called for its downfall
I have repeatedly called it a murderous
regime that belongs in the Dustbin of
History
my advisory role at niacc which I used
to have is because I am an expert on
religion and politics so I advise the
plowshares fund I advise Nyack I advise
the [ __ ] State Department I advise
actual Congress people who are making
these these these uh decisions about
what to do with Iran I'm an expert in
Iran so I advise those groups I have no
loyalty or membership to Nayak I'm not
here to speak for to be fair you don't
advise the other side though you're
strictly advising the progressive side
you're not advice you're 100 which they
support the nuclear deal which you
support as well it's a hundred percent
so you support negotiating with a nation
that says
death upon America you're comfortable
negotiating with a country that hates us
I'm sorry who do we negotiate we only
negotiate with countries that love us is
that how negotiations work have you
heard of the phrase diplomacy but
diplomacy no negotiation with a country
that
but for the most part the countries were
negotiated with that disagree with us
they don't say death upon Americans Iran
says death upon Americans the top of the
Iran this is not even the people in the
streets give us a [ __ ] so what so give
150 billion dollars that's a valid
concern that's a valid question first of
all it's their money that we are
releasing in exchange for removing
nuclear weapons from Iran how do you
suggest we remove nuclear weapons from
Iran Patrick okay I I have ideas I can
give it to you not to remove nuclear
weapons first of all do you believe no
matter whether we give them the money or
not they're not going to continue
working on nuclear weapons they
literally didn't but nope we're not
going to move past this until we
establish the facts the jcpoa which was
negotiated by the United States Russia
China the security Council and Germany
which is extraordinary the idea that
those five countries came together and
the European Union and agreed on
anything let alone agreed on this
absolutely remarkable deal under the
Obama Administration to remove all the
enriched uranium out of Iran
there is zero doubt that that worked
zero the iaea came out in no uncertain
terms and said within 12 months of that
deal being put in place Iran no longer
had the enriched uranium to create a
nuclear bomb within you have to be naive
to believe that okay but fair enough
let's let's let's buy into the naivete
and move forward okay let's just say
you're right let's say you're right
let's not believe the people on the
ground not actually monitoring the new
to believe somebody that believes in the
values that they do yes I don't believe
that but let me go to the next one ask
you the question let me go to the next
one I'll ask you a quick alternative let
me go back to the next one I'll ask you
the question okay
uh your father was right about Humanity
Fair yeah absolutely your father was
right so do you think a uh uh Iran and I
know this is going to be hard for you to
answer this question don't go mosade I'm
purely talking Shah and the advancements
we were making under Shaw versus what
happened to Iran under Khomeini okay
if
we had a choice between the two we this
is not the you can't say why I would
choose this I wouldn't choose either if
you had a choice between how Iran was
during Shahs error versus Khomeini which
would you choose neither I knew you were
going to say that but you can't say
neither you cannot say how do you mean
neither how can you say neither be
honest I mean I'm being serious with you
you may you may literally have this idea
about the Shaw's age that is that is in
your imagination I do not have an idea I
remember the thousands of people that he
slaughtered on the street the tens of
thousands of people who would disappear
into education camps we replaced one
murderous regime with another murderous
regime and it's stupid to say which one
would you prefer it's it's naive for you
to say what you just said
you said since you've left Iran in 79
till today Adam asks you a question
when's the last time you visited you
said 2005 before I became famous you
didn't use the word famous but before I
became known in a Marketplace okay you
haven't gone back since under shot you
could go back this is not about saying
one did it right or one did it wrong is
your question which is more beneficial
to me or which is better for Iran it's
by the way the shot was more beneficial
to the people you're saying Romania is
more beneficial to the people [ __ ] no
that's not what I said so the question
I'm asking is literally what is more
beneficial I can't say neither though
you are telling me which murderous
regime would you prefer the murderous
regime of the Shah or the murderers you
cannot be that naive though you cannot
be that naive listen if you take it from
that route if you take it from that
route
which by the way for me an imperialist
model apocalypse I'm not an imperialist
my model would be more what we have in
America what I'm asking you a simple
question you can't answer during
Khomeini millions of people died from
other countries
other innocent people died because of
khomeini's policies and his regime
this is not Reza palavis other people
died because of his regime you can't
give that argument okay for you to say
that I'm going to choose both what you
want to do is a fun intellectual
exercise in which you are saying gun to
my head I can only pick the murderous
regime of the Shah or the murderous
regime of the eye it's totally different
which one would you want I would say the
murderous regime of the Shah okay so
because you got a gun to my head not
because I got a gun to your head because
logically it makes sense to say right
after Khomeini you're probably not
leaving Iran if shall was still uh in
Iran or not being in Iran you probably
would and I would probably and I'd be
probably miserable I wouldn't I wouldn't
have no you wouldn't have right I don't
think so I disagree you would have
chosen to leave to another country you
would have chosen to come down I think
you've got a Nostalgia for the days of
the show I don't have a Nostalgia a lot
of like make America great but this but
this to me takes you back to why Nayak
gets the criticism that it does but
because for you you're saying give 150
billion dollars to those guys to Iran
it's their money
but you're saying it's their money
anyways you're putting words in my mouth
we have two options okay with Iran's
nuclear program two options and nothing
else two options period we have a third
option what's the third option I'll give
you the third option option one we blow
the [ __ ] out of it okay option two we
use negotiation and diplomacy what's
your third option very simple it's very
simple what you do with option three
option three is the same exact thing
that happened in different nations Iran
Iran is going through a potential
Revolution today hold on I want to make
it clear I am talking about 2012. I am
not talking about 2022. I'm not I have
never said we should renegotiate the the
nuclear program now you're asking me did
I support the jcpoa versus today today
there's no country let me tell you let
me take but let me make sure
loses it's [ __ ] I'm glad you clarify
that I am not saying that 10 years so
then was it right in 2012 a hundred
percent let me make my point let me make
my point on what I'm thinking and I want
to hear your rebuttal on this and your
argument on this for me it's the
following
uh have you heard of John Perkins the
economic Hitman guy the author he's the
hardcore Progressive very very
interesting guy I had him on two times I
really like talking to that guy uh and
it's very interesting his arguments what
they did you know to cause Nations to go
down do you think the current model and
the government today in Iran is good for
its people and good for the world [ __ ]
no okay fair weren't on the same page so
is it fair to say that if we can figure
out a way to help the Iranian people not
the government the Iranian people to
cause a fall in Iran that's probably a
good Noble thing for us to do that's
that has been my goal for 20 years
fantastic then if doing that
your mission of wanting to do that which
nyack's mission is for the people
policies to help with the people
that doesn't align with the rulers and
the president and the people that run
Iran you guys don't share a common value
you're wrong so you're telling me you're
telling me the foreign minister Javad
zarif like you're saying his ideal
situation is to bring democracy to Iran
no what you're saying is
can we pursue policies in the United
States to help the people of Iran and
have we been my answer is we have not
been we have not 40 Years of blanket
sanctions has not helped the people of
Iran it is only entrenched the
government further and there's reams of
academic data that can that indicates
that the question is does the for
instance nuclear deal the jcpoa in 2012
did that help would that have helped the
government or the people and there is
very good real like meaningful arguments
to be made that it it would only help
the government I disagree because there
are much better arguments that it would
only help people why it goes back to
your God capitalism the free market the
Iranian people live in an oppressive
murderous
Theocratic regime and as a part of
American policy we have decided that
we're going to blanket sanction everyone
in the hopes that eventually they'll
rise up and take down their government
no for decades four decades we've been
doing that now instead the argument of
the jcpoa was very simple a we get to
get rid of Iran's nuclear capabilities
without launching like giving them 150
billion without again I want to make
sure that you understand that this isn't
my 150 million or your 150 million
that's the only reason I said it doesn't
matter you're strengthening them what
you are doing you're strengthening their
government it's not about the money that
you give them
liberalization you cannot be that naive
to think the money goes to the people
I'm not talking about the money going to
the people what I am talking about is
the policies that arise from the jcpoa
which requires the liberalization of
Iran's economy what Iran what the
Iranian people not gonna happen what the
Iranian people need in order to actually
succeed in bringing down their
government is access to the free market
is access to the rest of the world
like giving money to the government
you are conflating two different things
listen to me I'm not saying that the
money in exchange for the nuclear
weapons is what is going to free Iran I
am saying that the policies pursued by
the jcpoa have on top of it the goal of
economic liberalization in Iran which is
why I argued 10 years ago that Iran
should be allowed into the World Trade
Organization because then it would have
to actually pursue policies that require
economic liberalism reason unreasonable
people it's impossible to negotiate with
unreasonable who we read do you know how
much [ __ ] we send to North Korea right
now do you know how many billions of
dollars in Aid we send to North Korea is
there anyone more unreasonable than Kim
Jong-un that's who we negotiate with is
unreasonable people because the other
option with unreasonable people don't
bring is you just bomb the [ __ ] don't
put as I know you're a hardcore
capitalist as a capitalist yourself
don't confuse the two okay with a
judeo-christian nation that we're
talking about here I'm not talking about
North Korea here I'm talking
specifically to Iran if you go back and
you think about during the Shah era when
that place is safe everybody around them
felt safe nobody around Iran feels safe
right nobody in Iran felt safe in this
shot of course they did of course it's
called when your family did yours did as
well what are you talking about are you
your example is the perfect one the
moment shall live your dad as a
communist left what are you talking
about my father didn't you feel safe
then why didn't he leave under the shot
why did he leave Rocco many came in you
realize how much hypocrisy there is for
that though there's contradiction to
that but let me a lot of things about
you I never honestly thought that you
were gonna sit here and actually defend
the [ __ ] shot are you kidding me
you're defending Khomeini you're
defending Iran you're defending all the
people
you chose 50 50. hold on have has anyone
here actually
indirectly you are indirectly you are
when I ask you between the Sean the
Khomeini you said that's neither will
you talk Romanians are the same you have
to be naive to say that I didn't say
they were the same what I said was but
you're family to be fair your murderous
regime baby I left the medianized I left
89. okay my family was actually the
family that I thought Iran was going to
figure that I'm part of that family yeah
if I would have left early okay if I had
your father I would have been like hey
man we're in we're in U.S already I
would have a 10 year lead but my dad
took 10 more years with mom because they
thought that this thing's going to get
figured out right all I'm saying to you
right now is the final one
I have four kids
I would love to take my kids to Iran
to jam Hospital
I'd love to go eat at albeli jigar do
original duel I dream about it to you
know uh uh what's that one park park is
shahan Shahi it's a different name right
now whatever it's called or go to bandar
palavi it's not called bandar palavi
anymore my mother said they're from uh
rasht and bandar palabi area yeah it's
my dream to go there I think my opinion
by giving these guys even if it's their
money back to make the government even
stronger you're delaying those people
being free you're delaying at 10 15 20
more years let's let's establish what's
your goal for Iran
my goal for Iran is to be a nation that
is Freer than it is today okay free such
as the exact same goal we do but our
approaches are different how do you
think we get to a Freer now it's in 45
years yeah it's been 45 years we're
we've done one thing all we have done
for 45 years is sanction contain and
isolate 45 years now you tell me yeah
have we gotten
this much closer to the Iran that you're
asking for so so let me let me you're
saying American policy yeah American I
understand sanctions isolation by the
way can you tell us to tell the people
to get on the zoom I'm six minutes late
I'm gonna be there in four minutes tell
me have we have we have we actually
pursued your goal have we pursued our
goal So my answer is going to upset you
okay and just brace for impact maybe
take a deep breath and then and then
you're probably gonna upset me as well
but but you know my answers these are my
answers
I think there are a lot of people in the
world
that want to keep Iran in the Havoc that
it is today absolutely I think there's a
lot of people that if they see Arabia
Israel it's not just Saudi Arabia or
Israel there's a lot of people here it's
UK it's a lot of people the last time
Iran was very powerful they became a
little too powerful and they're like
wait a minute pump your brakes my people
are going to your place Elizabeth Taylor
is dating zahidi Frank Sinatra's coming
up performing concerts in Iran the
richest people in the world in the 70s
are going to Iran for vacation the top
three country in the world countries in
the world for vacation is Iran are you
out of your freaking mind they're
killing it guys we got to kind of slow
they need havoc in the Middle East it's
a necessity for some financially it's a
necessity for some politically it's a
it's just like what we're talking about
the Iranian people let me it's the same
as this policy Iranian it's the same way
as many Progressive not you or Democrats
would like to keep certain communities
and sects poor because they keep winning
that vote if they lose that vote
if they start becoming financials
for a minute we're not getting off the
subject what I'm saying too is I'm
giving you my opinion I don't think they
want to free it having said that my
Approach
would be any possible way to give the
power to the people anyway how do we
give the power to them they need weapons
in Iran the people don't have weapons
We're Not Gonna We're Not Gonna ship
weapons to Iran like if you're asking me
a question let's talk about the realm of
the possible no no the realm of the
possible is not logical what needs to be
done is not on freaking black and white
it's a lot of gray needs to get done for
this thing to get done it ain't no black
and white type of stuff you need a
similar situation on what happened with
most other and what happened with the
child as crazy as this sounds they've
done this before to a guy that would be
considered a republican the Shah and
they did it to a guy that would have
been seen as a socialists how you think
we help the people in Iran is by giving
them weapons that is one of many
different ways to do it one of many
different ways to do it that's one of
the ways to do it how do we Empower
those people to actually be able to
remove their government by suffocating
their government how do we suffer by the
government why do you think all these
girls right now willing to sacrifice
their lives for what though do you think
what do you think the woman right now
are doing in Iran what do you think
they're doing it they're sacrificing
their lives basic human rights basic
human rights things that you and I have
here absolutely I support that and I
support the more we strengthen their
government the less power we give them
so the more money we give to the
government the less money we give to
that's how we give to them right so how
so you do realize that right now the
rich people in Iran are the people in
government the mullahs with the roles I
don't disagree
45 years of sanctions has made the
people poor and the government Rich no
what they do is the government from the
top says see what America did to you
right see what America did to you take
it off no no see we take it all and then
Aus send us more money or else we're
going to keep saying mad bad on recall
we're going to keep saying America's the
evil empire that's what they do no it's
not about American Empire it's about an
existential threat to the world Iran has
it no no Iran has money it's not like
Iran doesn't have money the level of uh
yeah again let's not confuse things the
nuclear deal was to get nuclear weapon
capabilities out of Iran and it was
according to your strengthening the
government according to five countries
in order to do that so here now here's
the question here's the question to you
you're saying that for 45 years the
government has gotten richer and the
people have gotten poorer yes and that's
because the government has a monopoly on
the black market so I'm saying actually
let's invest in the free market let's
give the people you're naive to think
the money most of them the money goes to
them four degrees I don't have a degree
the money goes to them if they actually
have an ability to access it if they
have access to the free market economy
if they have access to interdependence
access to that
desire if you're a business owner in
Iran let's say you're selling carpets
Iran's business you're selling you're
selling pistachios yes you can't sell
pistachios on the international market
so that's not about the mulas keeping
all the money for them they can yeah the
fact of the matter is and for a
capitalist like you I can't believe
you're disagreeing with this I'm against
the government having the power to bully
its people which is what it's been doing
for 44 years you're for it I'm against
it that's [ __ ] and then say that I'm
for it and what do you mean give them
the 150 billion dollars to the
government your argument is that if
you're saying the argument is let them
have their money that's theirs you're
not thinking we're strengthening them I
think we have a common Mission by the
way my argument I'm not going to say
this one last time is that in exchange
in 20 2012 for the removal of nuclear
weapons capability you're believing them
for in exchange for nuclear weapons
capabilities which have the stringest
investigative group The iaea now you can
say oh [ __ ] the iaea [ __ ] the U.N they
all don't know anything okay well then
there's nothing really to talk about but
the people on the ground who actually
take the tests told us in no uncertain
terms that it was working that's a fact
the point is separate that from this
larger conversation that we're having
which is how do you empower the people
in Iran to bring down their governments
and it's a legitimate argument I'm not
saying you're wrong or dumb for thinking
that you know sanctions are the right
way of doing it they're not dumb it's
naive it's two differences what I'm what
I'm saying is yeah there are two ways to
do this
you could either blanket sanction the
entire country and as we know 45 years
of that has led to the the uh government
being more entrenched than it's ever
been and the people at the top being
billionaires and everyone else barely
struggling
or any other thing 45 years any other
thing and what is the other thing well
it's quite easy there are mechanisms in
place already that allow for an
investment on the ground of the Iranian
people themselves access to the free
market economy which comes with rules
here's the problem with 45 what rules
the rules are World Bank rules rules are
you you okay so so so if I negotiate
with a murderer you think he's
accustomed to
following the rules if I if I negotiate
with a nation with a government like
theirs you think they follow what's in a
contracts it's so there's no way you
believe that I understand that you have
this this mystical view of what the
Iranian government is that exists in
this kind of existence
people who care about their own
livelihood and they care about nothing
else I do think they care about their
livelihood the government people care
about their wealth I agree with you
exactly but but I'm talking about its
people that's what I'm talking about and
what I'm saying is
right now we have nothing but the stick
we have no carrot at all in Iran there's
nothing that you can carry to the wrong
guy you're giving Terror to the guy
that's got plenty of cares he's been
overdosing on we're giving carrot to the
economy no you're not giving it here
today
I'm a Syrian on Armenia let me tell you
what both sides will say you ready
here's a criticism here's a criticism
both sides will say and I want to wrap
it I will go off if you're up for uh
part two three hours I'm up for bringing
you back you have no idea how many I've
enjoyed I'm being serious okay so I'll
tell you this Armenian Assyrian
Assyrian Armani okay
you know every time when people say Hey
you know let me tell you what's going to
send money to this charity
send money to go help the Assyrians how
come you're not giving money here and
I'll send money you know both sides of
my family will say never send money you
know why because it goes to the wrong
people because it never goes to its
people you said it you know this
reputation so if you and I are given
money
150 Billy to the government we have to
be naive to believe it's going to end up
to its people that's what I'm not going
to end up to its people and that's what
that's we're strengthening it's
something different okay anyway hold on
hold on I I need to say one last thing
because if you probably know anything
about me you know that I get cut up and
re-edited and there's an entire industry
online meant to make me look in a
certain that's not us we don't do I want
to say something I want to say a final
word here because it's very important
yeah and I'm hoping that this final word
will make it
I have absolutely nothing but loathing
for the Iranian government for the
Islamic Republic it is a murderous
terroristic regime that Slaughters its
own children it has no legitimacy
whatsoever it belongs in the Dustbin of
History the only proper response of this
current Revolution and it is a
revolution it is a revolution is not for
reform it's not for a little bit more
right it's to burn the whole thing down
and start all over again and I
wholeheartedly support that the question
is how do we Empower those young people
how do we give them the rules necessary
in order to burn it down next that's the
difference next time how about we do
this next time we just do podcasts on
Iran not religion so we're like and it's
just going to be you and I don't know
well no no and by the way just so you
know what you just said that's a clip
and we're gonna put the entire clip of
Iran me and you going back and forth and
your last part will be in it as well as
a closing just sign us to the audience
we don't play those games please tell us
about your new book
the book is a biography of Howard
Baskerville who is a 22 year old
Christian Missionary from Nebraska in
1907 he got assigned to Tabriz the city
of Tabriz in Iran to go preach the
gospel and teach English and he showed
up in the middle of Iran's first
Revolution the Constitutional revolution
of 1905 he showed up in 1907 in the
middle of it this was the first
Democratic revolution in the entire
Middle East it led to the first
Constitution and also a parliament in
Iran the Shah launched a war against the
the constitutionalists that war kind of
culminated in the city of Tabriz and at
that moment Howard basketball this 22
year old Christian Missionary gave up
his missionary post and his American
citizenship and joined the
revolutionaries in this fight against
the Shah for democracy they won they
they beat the Shah they they exiled him
they established the Constitution and
they established a parliament Iran was a
constitutional monarchy for a very very
short amount of time until Reza Pahlavi
the father of the man that you your hero
the father of the man that you weirdly
seem to have some Nostalgia for father
of the men
he was a he was uh he was declared a
military declared a military coup on
Iran brought down the Parliament and
feared man
well the point is this incredible story
of this American Christian who is still
considered a hero in Iran today rap Link
in the chat Link in description folks go
buy the book uh he has a track record of
writing books that gets people thinking
talking debating Reza once again truly
thank you so much for coming out I will
not wait for the next one this two hours
for like two minutes to me I appreciate
you
come back on everything let's go to Iran
together bro let's go to Iran together
next year in Tehran next year
thank you everybody have a great weekend
we're now doing another one this week
we'll do it again next week take care
bye-bye